Virginia is next and that's Christopher
calling from Virginia hi Christopher how
are you
they have them on there better than I
deserve what's up I got a question uh me
and my wife Mary Kylie about two years
and she's working now off to come home a
once I three year old child until he
turns old enough to go to school and I'm
not quite fed only because we currently
have 2,500 left for a car that we
purchase and she is getting a master's
degree in health administration which is
about seventy two thousand five hundred
give or take five hundred you're gonna
stay at home why did you get a master's
degree I said the same thing Dave let's
try to figure it out because I make
about 9,200 myself so I can definitely
float it but given that we have this
amount of debt in her through the loans
which is really ours since we're married
how much is this going on that I still
own that seventy two thousand and five
hundred I believe and what is sure does
she make right now she makes roughly
about six hundred every two weeks six
hundred dollars every two weeks yes you
those little building I guess is collar
until she can get into her helping
ministry also she's not and she finished
as she finished the master's no she'll
be done in December oh okay is she
planning to finish the master's uh yeah
I mean that that's forgiven I see it
this way you know she has the pencil
I've got no gripe with getting a masters
and I've got no gripe with being a
full-time mom with a master's it I'm a
little bit going you just spent seventy
two thousand bucks for seventy two
thousand dollars in debt to get this
master's maybe we ought to use that and
go pay off the debt that's what I'm
thinking just have her cook like I said
we can do the the power of one basically
let her pay for her school loans and
I'll just float the bills you know or
even more I think you can guys can
crunch it down more than that I mean if
you got a hundred and seventy thousand
dollar
$180,000 income you don't need to just
live off a hundred let's crunch it down
even further than that
I don't mind us being very very
aggressive but she's probably working a
good year anyway to get this mess paid
off which I mean is yeah yeah yeah I
don't know it's because with with my
hundreds that I make a year like I said
I can definitely assist with because we
can probably live off 2,000 every uh it
wouldn't even be as bad if you are fit
just finished your masters and then set
up I changed my mind I'm gonna go home
if you didn't have seventy two thousand
dollars in debt to go with it uh yeah I
mean that's just that's just hard to
swallow I don't um I mean she makes her
sound kind of fickle actually she
probably isn't but it makes her sound
that way the way we're talking this
through so I don't know man it would be
hard for me I wanted to be at home if
that's where she wants to be but it'd be
really hard for me it with that seventy
two thousand dollars in debt that we
just incurred to complete a master's
that she's not using that would just
that would drive me nuts this is the
Dave Ramsey show
hey guys Rachael Cruz here hope you
enjoyed that video from the Dave Ramsey
show if you want to watch another great
video check out my video three things
you should consider renting right over
here or click the link in the
description below
you